have you guys ever experienced what
thirst is not having to drink a single
drop of water for days these people have
our fridges are full of water please
give whatever you can for the sake of
allah so they can have something to
drink
i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran salaam
welcome to this video guys do not forget
before you carry watch this video please
help me to reach my target to build
water worlds inshallah in the countries
that need it the most brothers and
sisters and give even if it's two pounds
it's a salad dried for you in this video
we're going to be watching a video that
if i'm mistaken this is in a shopping
center it looks like it's london of a
tick-tock of a female who's obviously
dancing or doing some kind of seductive
moves on the escalators and there and
right behind her is a man let's see the
reaction of this man and why did he
react in this way because it's very very
key for us to understand this in
specifically in the 21st century
as you guys saw the moment he realized
that that girl is dancing in a
provocative way or whatever it may be he
turned his face around now the question
i want to ask is which religion which
way of life yeah which
philosophy teaches you that you should
look away when a woman dances in a
specific way that might turn an
individual on or whatever it may be as
men our biggest weakness is opposite
gender and they do not realize this and
the point i'm trying to make here is
this he chose to look away these kind of
men i admire these kind of men i look up
to i genuinely look up to these and
i really
love and honor them so much and no other
way of life except islam teaches a man
how to respect a woman to this degree
that he doesn't even want to look at her
in that sexual way and he turns his face
around we are told that we objectify
women by telling them to wear the hijab
and they'll abaya no islam is a
realistic religion it reduces reality
not dreams
islam tells that a man has to do his bit
on a micro level which is what which we
have to teach our kids our sons not just
our daughters our sons that they should
not be looking at inappropriate things
and if they do to lower the gaze and
where does this come from this comes
from our holy scripture the quran where
allah says tell the believing men to
lower their gaze he also tells the woman
but before the women he tells the men to
lower their gifts gaze what does that
show us it shows us on a micro level to
a macro level god almighty does not want
us to sexually objectify women and in
the 21st century we live the women are
devalued degraded like prostitutes
excuse my language
they are made to feel devalued and think
that the only thing that they have to
offer are their body parts the breasts
the thighs the back side the lips
whatever you want to call it and islam
says no and that's the reason why this
is one of the most beautiful religion
in in the world why because it's telling
you a reality because it's telling us
that the heart doesn't desire what the
eyes don't see
and we ask allah to make every single
one of us including me to be able to be
strong
that we lower our gazes
period
and this is why it's so important
brothers and sisters that shows that
islam is the religion that honors women
to such a level like i said before that
this man lowers his case he doesn't want
to see that he doesn't want to look at
her in that way and what does he do he
lowers his gaze
and one of the people that's going to be
under the shade of god almighty which we
believe on the day of judgment seven
people one of them who the man who is in
a room with a woman and a woman of
beauty and stature
and she tries to
seduce him to sleep with him and he says
i fear my lord
we do this for the sake of god and i
found this so beautiful and i want you
guys to share this far and wide
specifically to your non-muslim
female friends
show them how beautiful islam is and we
hope and ask allah to make every muslim
man
like this guy so all i had to say
brothers and sisters assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh